mais d'abord on vous emmène dans les
coulisses des négociations chez LFI le
PS vend chèrement son intégration à la
nouvelle union Marion Delpech après
l'alliance nouée avec les écologistes
les insoumis finalisés à la mi-journée
en accord avec le Parti communiste
français alors que les négociations se
poursuivent encore avec le Parti
socialiste en cette date symbolique du 3
mai où le Front populaire était sorti
victorieux des législatives de 1936 en
pleine négociation aujourd'hui
l'insoumisé euro député Manon Aubry
était optimiste
voilà vous l'avez compris l'histoire est
en train de s'écrire en ce genre de
l'anniversaire du Front populaire et on
espère que la dernière partie prenante
qui est pas des moindres le Parti
socialiste sera en capacité de nous
rejoindre un souhait partagé par le chef
des négociateurs socialistes pierre
Jouvet malgré quelques dossiers épineux
toujours sur la table la question du
projet la question européenne fait
encore partie des éléments sur lesquels
on discute la question de la stratégie
évidemment la question des répartitions
vous l'avez tous compris territorial et
donc des circonscriptions mais certains
se rebiffent contre ce potentiel accord
a commencé par le négociateur du Nouveau
parti anticapitaliste il estime que la
présence du Parti socialiste pose
problème parce que c'est le représentant
depuis 20 ans des politiques libérales
qui ont été menées dans le pays
rébellion aussi en interne un millier de
cadres social
istes cet accord et dénonce une
reddition dans cette missive rédigée par
la mère de veau en Velin mais l'horloge
tourne et les socialistes devront
rapidement se positionner le négociateur
de la France insoumise manuel Bompard
fixe la fin de la journée pour parvenir
à un accord on a une convention
législative qui est prévue samedi pour
pouvoir la préparer ensemble dans des
bonnes conditions et c'est ce que l'on
souhaite ça nécessite d'avoir un petit
peu de temps aussi donc oui il faut que
ça se termine d'ici la fin de la journée
le Parti socialiste préservera-t-il ses
25 députés sortants et obtiendra-t-il
d'autres circonscriptions gagnables les
points de blocage seront-ils levés pour
parvenir à un accord réponse dans la
soirée
l'actualité politique de cette journée
passée au tamis de l'analyse de nos
experts on va parler évidemment de
l'Alliance à gauche mais aussi des
tractations au sein de la République en
marche et de la première interview
d'Éric Zemmour c'était sur BFM hier soir
j'accueille mes invités leur Salva
bonsoir directrice de l'Institut de
sondage Cantat Jean-Loup Missika bonsoir
vous êtes responsavistorial du sac de
réflexion Terranova co-auteur avec Henri
Verdier de du business de la haine
internet la démocratie et les réseaux
sociaux c'est publié aux éditions Calman
Levi j'accueille également Frédéric
potier bonsoir bienvenue à vous experts
associés à la Fondation Jean Jaurès et
vous publiez un thriller politique la
menace 732 s'est apparaître le 19 mai
aux Éditions de l'Aube noir et c'est
déjà disponible
précommande avis aux amateurs Laetitia
cruppa éditoris petit bonsoir Laetitia
comment vous dire j'ai l'impression d'un
jour sans fin c'est vrai j'ai commencé
mon émission hier soir en disant on est
dans l'attente de la signature du Parti
socialiste en cette fin et c'est la même
phrase que je prononce pour démarrer ce
soir mais quand même leur Salvin sans
préjugés de ce que sera la décision de
des socialistes est-ce que vous diriez
qu'on est en train d'assister à une
vraie recomposition du paysage politique
où est-ce que c'est une fin de
décomposition vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est vraiment une étape majeure
pour vous je pense que on avait le
sentiment que 2017 était une parenthèse
à un moment donné dans la vie politique
française et finalement on voit bien que
c'est aujourd'hui 2022 c'est la
poursuite de 2027 de 2017 et finalement
avec cette transformation du paysage
politique qui s'accentue aujourd'hui
avec cette union de la gauche alors
certains diront que c'est de la cuisine
politicienne je ne suis pas sûr
effectivement que la plupart des
citoyens français s'intéressent vraiment
à ces sujets ce qui est certain c'est
qu'on ne peut plus aujourd'hui
considérer que le Parti socialiste reste
le Parti socialiste comme il a été comme
il a comment dire porter ses valeurs
pendant des dizaines d'années jusqu'à
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les gens qui se
disent de gauche ne se reflètent pas
forcément dans des valeurs justement du
Parti socialiste traditionnel d'autres
au contraire sont de plus en plus
proches aussi de la République en marche
enfin voilà donc tout ça est en train
d'être remouliné et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on assiste finalement à
des prises de parole très différentes de
la part
des barons du Parti socialiste et je
pense que ça ça ne fait qu'ajouter du
trouble aux citoyens qui qui sont un peu
en manque de repères dans ce paysage
politique assez éclaté aujourd'hui
Jean-Louis vous connaissez bien le Parti
Social vous avez été adjoint à la mairie
à en Hidalgo à la mairie de Paris
pendant plusieurs années est-ce que vous
diriez que c'est une scission tout
simplement qui se prépare au sein du
Parti socialiste je pense qu'il y a pas
mal de gens aux parties socialistes qui
ne sont pas d'accord avec cette alliance
avec avec la France insoumise donc c'est
sûr que ça pose plus de problèmes cette
alliance au Parti socialiste que ça n'en
a posé par exemple aux parties
communistes voire à Europe Écologie Les
Verts maintenant surtout je pense que ce
qui est vraiment fondamental dans ce que
nous assistons c'est une sorte
d'inversion du rapport de force jusqu'à
présent depuis Mitterrand en
pratiquement donc depuis 1974 le grand
décompte ça remonte à loin le à gauche
c'était le parti de gouvernement qui
était central et le parti de
contestation qui était à côté et qui
négociait en position minoritaire que ce
soit les communistes ou les verts ou LFI
enfin le Parti de gauche comme on disait
avant et et là maintenant ce qu'a réussi
Mélenchon est assez extraordinaire il a
fait en sorte que la France insoumise
occupe la position centrale alors que
c'est un parti contestataire et ce sont
les parties de gouvernement qui sont les
forces d'appoint qui viennent négocier
les sièges margin que la force centrale
accepte de de lui ordonner et c'est pour
ça alors je partage point de vue de l'or
c'est à dire ça ça crée un peu le
trouble chez les chez les électeurs
parce que c'est assez nouveau et on ne
sait pas très bien où ça mène
c'est-à-dire est-ce que ce parti qui est
qui était considéré comme un parti
protestataire un parti tribunicien comme
des comme disent les politiques est-ce
que ce parti peut gouverner et c'est une
vraie question et effectivement Fred et
potier c'est plus facile d'être un parti
attrape tout au sein d'une famille
politique quand on occupe la position
centrale est-ce que elle est fille peut
prétendre à ce rôle c'est en partie la
réponse aux gens ils mais c'est presque
c'est presque de la géographie politique
quand on est à l'extrême c'est plus
difficile de jouer un rôle central
pardon c'est une lapalissade mais il
faut aussi le rappeler quoi et c'est
d'autant plus compliqué que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon a eu des propos très durs
radicaux il a campé la gauche de la
gauche pendant toute la campagne
présidentielle et là il lui faut faire
un petit virage pour attirer à lui des
socialistes humanistes des
socio-démocrates et ça va pas de soi
ça va pas de choix parce qu'on touche à
l'ADN en fait du Parti socialiste on
parle de l'Europe on parle de laïcité on
parle de politique économique et donc la
grande différence je trouve avec les
heures glorieuses du Front populaire ou
avec 80 ou avec 97 c'était qu'au fond
ces accords de gouvernement ils ont été
préparés très en amont il y a de longues
discussions pour aboutir au programme
gouvernement et là on a l'impression
qu'en deux trois nuits de négociations
et bien finalement les désaccords
pourraient se dissiper et on pourrait
aboutir un accord surtout électoral donc
effectivement ça crée beaucoup de
troubles ça crée du trouble chez les
socialistes mais je pense ça trouble
aussi l'opinion publique assez largement
ça va vite pardon mais parce qu'il n'y a
pas justement de programmes communs la
proposition de la France insoumise elle
est radicale c'est venait avec moi mais
avec nos conditions et puis peut-être à
la marge on verra si on peut faire un
effort sur les vôtres mais les 10 points
qu'ils ont mis sur la table sont non
négociables donc il n'y a pas de
programme commun c'est la gauche sur le
programme de la France insoumise c'est
ça qui pose un problème aussi pour les
électeurs parce que quand on est
socialiste si effectivement ils avaient
revu certains points à la baisse ou
s'ils avaient accepté en tout cas
d'aller sur les propositions des eaux de
ces forces qui vont venir grossir cette
espèce de gauche oui un peu protéiforme
les électeurs auraient pu s'y retrouver
mais là ça veut dire que électeur
socialiste on va aller voter aux
législatives pour un candidat qui ne
portera pas
nos convictions c'est compliqué quand
même à expliquer à con pour convaincre
le Europe Écologie Les Verts ils ont
quand même balayé ça rapidement c'est
sans doute là-dessus que ça coince le
plus peut-être aussi sur le nombre de
circonscriptions gagnables soyons pas
angélique mais si on parle que des
programmes l'Europe quand même
Jean-Louis la sollicité aussi l'Europe
est une pomme de discorde considérable
et notamment la fameuse phrase sur la
désobéissance la désobéissance au traité
que les que les ouvert les vers ce soit
contentés d'une petite d'un petit peu
difficile disant dans le respect de
l'État de droit ça oxymore absolument
extraordinaire parce que à partir du
moment où vous désobéissent un traité
plus sortez de l'État de droit donc tout
ça tout ça n'a absolument aucun sens et
on voit bien qu'effectivement bon c'est
c'est un compromis qui n'en est pas un
mais moi ce qui me frappe aussi c'est
cette espèce de de volonté de la part du
Parti socialiste de de
d'accepter beaucoup de choses qui
auraient été considéré comme des lignes
rouges il y a pas il n'y a pas si
longtemps et côté Mélenchon c'est là où
il a un vrai talent politique c'est un
véritable tour de passe-passe qu'il a
fait parce que grosso modo quand vous
regardez les sondages jour du vote vous
voyez que 50% 50% des gens qui ont voté
Mélenchon
l'ont fait dans un esprit de vote utile
c'est-à-dire n'était pas favorable à
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et à la totalité de
son programme et peut-être dans d'autres
circonstances auraient voté écologistes
ou socialiste et en réalité il récupère
tout cet électorale et il dit ben voilà
je pèse 22 % maintenant nous allons
répartir les sièges sur la basse ont
voté Emmanuel Macron donc c'est pas non
plus
qu'on radical de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
parce que là il y a un temps médiatique
on est dedans on y participe en faisant
ces débats mais il y a un temps
médiatique de la gauche qui sera
d'ailleurs sans doute qui va laisser la
place ensuite à un temps macroniste avec
l'investiture avec le Premier ministre
le nouveau gouvernement etc mais ça ne
préjuge en rien de l'attitude des
électeurs dans six semaines absolument
non seulement de l'attitude des
électeurs qui eux certainement on parle
de sens justement à cette émission
s'appelle sens public quel est le sens
de ces négociations pour les électeurs
qu'est-ce que ça leur apporte très
concrètement donc on voit bien ce que ça
peut apporter à certains hommes
politiques certains hommes politiques
mais eux on voit pas trop et puis aussi
il y a ceux qu'on oublie ce sont les
élus locaux qui sont sur le terrain
depuis déjà 5 ans certains vont devoir
peut-être partir à la faveur 2 etc
tous ne vont pas forcément suivre enfin
donc je crois qu'on oublie aussi
les territoires à la fois les citoyens
mais aussi tous les qui sont en place
depuis de nombreuses années qui ont fait
qui ont œuvré pour leur territoire qui
sont connus etc et comme vous le disiez
il risque y avoir énormément de
candidatures dissidentes ce qui
aboutirait finalement à l'inverse de ce
qu'on cherche à faire en ce moment en
faisant les efforts le désir d'unité de
la part de l'électorat de gauche déjà on
l'a vu avant la prise avant on l'a vu
dans le score de Mélenchon on a vu que
le principe du vote utile a été un
puissant facteur d'accélération dans la
dernière ligne droite et c'est comme ça
qu'il est arrivé jusqu'à 22% alors qu'il
était à 10% un mois auparavant quand
même il faut pas se oublier cette cette
évolution quand même de son score et et
je pense que ça traduit quand même une
demande d'unité alors une demande
d'unité qui chez les jeunes est assez
peu politisé c'est-à-dire que nous parce
que nous sommes des
nous avons une certaine expérience on
voit bien la différence qu'il y a entre
un parti de gouvernement et un parti
contestataire entre la gauche et
l'extrême gauche entre entre l'écologie
radicale et l'écologie
gouvernementale mais il y a toute une
demande je pense dans les jeunes
générations qui est en quelque sorte ils
veulent ils veulent que il y ait la
possibilité d'avoir une perspective
politique une perspective de victoire
quand Mélenchon dit il faut sortir de la
culture de la défaite il dit quelque
chose qui parle aux gens quand même et
pourtant et pourtant on va rappeler ça
Laetitia il a bien perdu le 24 avril
dernier oui parce qu'on a tendance à
l'oublier et il a bien raison de dire il
faut sortir de cette stratégie de la
défaite de cette mécanique infernale
pourquoi parce qu'il a quand même perdu
trois fois l'élection présidentielle je
le rappelle à chaque fois en entrée de
chronique parce que on l'oublie cette
semaine pourquoi on l'oublie parce que
sa communication est absolument efficace
c'est à dire qu'il a mis en place ce
qu'on appelle je sais pas un raid de
communication une opération de force et
c'est un cas d'école Esther qui
n'installe dans l'opinion publique
d'abord médiatique bien sûr mais public
une hypothèse totalement farfelue
qu'Emmanuel Macron le nommerait Premier
ministre parce que l'union de la gauche
aurait remporté des élections
législatives et il a il installe comme
un objectif politique réalisable et
alors dans cette stratégie de
communication elle est même si on
commence vraiment à essayer de
l'analyser monter comme une série il y a
du suspense bien sûr il y a le héros
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il y a bien sûr cette
Victor aussi et cet objectif du
troisième tour parce que c'est ce qui
nous a servi au départ on rentre dans le
troisième tour et donc il y a également
la participation et c'est plus important
du public c'est à dire que les électeurs
vont pouvoir faire gagner leur héros et
ça c'est donc vraiment c'est une
stratégie très très efficace le premier
épisode on est au soir du second tour et
oui il l'a dit il a commencé dès ce soir
là pourquoi parce qu'il a complètement
changé de discours oubliée les allez-y
faites mieux que moi qu'il avait lancé
aux jeunes générations je m'en vais je
me retire
je tire ma révérence bon bah alors là ça
a complètement changé mauvais perdant à
la fin de son discours il sait tout
simplement posé comme le seul l'unique
opposant à Emmanuel Macron en écoute
le Bloc populaire qui s'est constitué
autour de ma candidature à l'élection
présidentielle
est dans ce pays dorénavant le tiers
état qui peut tout changer s'il sera
rassemble et s'ils
le 12 et 19 juin
on vous appelant Amélie comme Premier
ministre
je vous appelle en vérité à faire vivre
un nouvel avenir en commun pour notre
peuple
j'appelle juste qu'il est 20h30 parce
que les prises de parole c'est Marine Le
Pen 20h15 et Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
s'apprêtait à parler attend un petit peu
il est 20h30 quoi il y a même pas eu 20
minutes de de place laisser au vainqueur
bref alors le Bloc populaire l’aurait
élu dit-il il faudrait quand même
définir ce que le Bloc populaire je
rappelle que des catégories populaires
ont voté majoritairement Marine Le Pen
mais il a enjambé aussi si je puis dire
Marine Le Pen hop ce n'est pas la
première opposante c'est moi ce qui est
intéressant dans cette offensive de
communication Thomas c'est qui bien sûr
qu'il y a les mots le tiers état enfin
bon ça fait appel à des références
historiques mais il y a aussi le visuel
et ses affiches Mélenchon Premier
ministre des tractins 2 millions de
tracts 200 000 affiches et là la France
insoumise dit que il y a une reddition
qui va être faite donc il faut vous avez
vu c'est une script quoi c'est
c'est bombing c'est à dire un tapis de
bombe on répète on répète on Martel et
si on n'a pas compris si on n'a pas
écouté on va me voir avec un slogan
Mélenchon Premier ministre et donc le
premier mai dimanche il a remis ça
jamais
une femme entrée dans une élection
législative dans d'aussi bonne condition
que cette fois-ci pourquoi la première
c'est que vous en êtes conscient partout
je passe partout passe mes camarades on
leur dit ah c'est bientôt le troisième
tour on se retrouve la consigne est
passée tout le monde a compris ce qu'on
a voulu dire quand on a dit qu'il
fallait que je sois le premier ministre
je lui a un reproche qui va bien pour
rigoler
[Applaudissements]
une élection pour dire qu'on va désigner
le Premier ministre c'est commencer à
mettre un peu de Sixième République dans
la cinquième donc
pourquoi a-t-il choisi de personnifier
autant ce troisième tour alors là il y a
plusieurs niveaux de lecture je vous en
donne deux le premier c'est bien sûr que
il joue son avenir parce qu'il me semble
quand même que si on va faire de la
politique fiction si c'est une union de
la gauche remporte législatives c'est
quand même le président qui nomme le
Premier ministre je ne crois pas
qu'Emmanuel Macron prendrait et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon mais on comprend que donc il
ne se retira pas de la vie politique et
qu'il sera le leader de l'opposition à
Emmanuel Macron le deuxième niveau de
lecture je pense qu'il savoure enfin sa
revanche sur le Parti socialiste qui l'a
délaissé ignorait moquer voire humilié
et donc voilà c'est enfin l'heure de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon le vilain petit
canard socialiste il sera un des
protagonistes de des protagonistes de
l'effondrement de ce parti free potier
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé entre entre
les aussi vite là entre les deux tours
de la de la présidentielle pourquoi
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui semblait laisser
la euh la main a une nouvelle génération
d'un seul coup euh ce placard comme ça
dans 200000 affiches c'est quoi c'est
l'ego qui reprend le dessus c'est c'est
la peur de passer de de c'est la peur de
la retraite je sais pas je mets de la
psychologie là-dedans comment vous
l'analysez vous il y a sans doute un peu
de tout ça mais moi je crois qu'il y a
aussi une stratégie qui est finement
pensée l'idée c'est de capitaliser sur
le score d'élection présidentielle ou
Mélenchon à incarner une forme d'espoir
et de vote utile à gauche sauf que là ce
que on voit à l'écran c'est quand même
une stratégie qui risque de laisser
aussi beaucoup de frustration parce que
ça sous-entendrait pour que ce bloc la
gagne d'avoir une majorité dans une
majorité de circonscription que le la
France insoumise soit elle-même
majoritaire dans ce bloc là et que
Emmanuel Macron le président de la
République qui lui a été élu il faut
aussi le rappeler se trouve contraint de
désigner Jean-Luc Mélenchon et donc moi
je trouve que c'est quand même un petit
peu dangereux pour la démocratie de
faire croire à des hypothèses dont les
conditions de la réalisation sont
extrêmement hypothétiques et en cela je
pense qu'on peut indiquer que cette
stratégie là elle est un tout petit peu
populiste surtout que vous l'avez dit
Laetitia mais il faut pas oublier leur
salvats que dans l'électorat populaire
il y a une autre marque qui imprime et
qui a beaucoup imprimé dans cette
présentiel c'est la marque Marine Le Pen
oui elle a marqué rassemblement national
et c'est vrai qu'on est assez étonné
finalement qu'il s'autoproclame genre
Mélenchon comme le principal opposant à
Emmanuel cracron alors que quand même il
n'a pas terminé ces élections
présidentielles en match contre contre
lui donc et puis de la même façon on en
parlait tout à l'heure sur le vote
populaire le vote populaire est
d'ouvriers notamment des ouvriers des
employés et des plus jeunes n'est pas
allé vers Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais plutôt
vers Marine Le Pen et c'est vrai que
c'est un peu la grande absente de de ces
discussions et c'est aussi un peu la
grande absente médiatique là depuis
depuis quelques jours c'est c'est assez
intéressant elle va forcément
réapparaître dans dans quelques jeux
dans quelques jours mais pour l'instant
elle est pas là je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde qui ont plutôt intérêt
justement comme Marine Le Pen y compris
comme Emmanuel Macron à rester plutôt en
retrait dans cette dans cette phase dans
cette séquence en fait des élections de
préparation des élections législatives
parce que finalement tout le monde est
en train de s'entretuer
sur le devant de la scène et les autres
vont paraître beaucoup plus raisonnables
et effectivement les deux derniers
finalistes ont apparaître comme quelque
part
plus déjà respectueux du vote
certainement des Français et du choix du
vote des Français à ce second tour et
puis aussi plus dans la mesure et dans
le temps de la réflexion là ça ferait un
peu précipiter alors vous disiez il y a
pas beaucoup de temps mais en effet ça
paraîtrait la jour et nuit c'est c'est
vraiment on est vraiment sur le sur le
front en permanence vous avez signé pour
Terra Nova une note intitulée La
Bataille des nostalgies quelle est la
nostalgie portée par le leader des
insoumis par Jean-Luc Mélenchon ah je
pense que c'est la nostalgie de ce qu'on
a appelé en fait de ce que ma génération
a appelé le socialisme réel le
socialisme réel c'était quoi c'est celui
qui était pratiqué dans les pays de
l'Est en Union soviétique en Chine parce
que quand vous regardez son programme
son programme est de ce point de vue là
c'est clair c'est un programme qui est
fondé sur des grands principes qui
rappellent par certains côtés mais qui
l'accentue le programme de de 1980 c'est
à dire des nationalisations
des niveaux d'imposition qui peuvent
atteindre des niveaux confiscatoires une
planification alors qu'on appelle plus
planification socialiste mais qu'on
appelle planification écologiste
et et
une hostilité radicale donc allant
jusqu'à la volonté de détruire le
capitalisme au profit d'une économie
d'État voilà ce qu'on appelle l'économie
administrée ou l'économie ou l'économie
planifiée donc de ce point de vue là on
a l'impression d'être face à quelque
chose enfin pour ce qui est de ma
génération bien sûr d'être face à
quelque chose qui a déjà été essayé et
qui a pas trop bien marché mais en même
temps on voit que le cette espèce de
discours de l'égalité de l'égalité
un peu radical à une très très grande à
une très grande efficacité et surtout
c'est un modèle césariste un peu qui qui
fonctionne bien en France l'homme
providentiel c'est-à-dire la France
insoumise n'est pas un parti politique
au sens traditionnel du terme de ce
point de vue là d'ailleurs ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que les trois
candidats qui ont gagné qui ont fait les
meilleurs scores la présidentielle sont
tous à la tête de parti politique sont
des parties personnelles enfin pour le
cas de Marine Le Pen familiale mais mais
mais ce sont ce sont des partis qui sont
centrés sur un seul homme et où c'est
l'homme en question ou la femme en
question qui décide de tout oui
d'ailleurs ça pose on y viendra dans un
instant la question de l'avenir du du
macronisme quand Emmanuel Macron sera
allé au bout de ce second mandat mais on
y viendra mais déjà le cas parce que
évidemment
c'est dès qu'il a été élu
ça c'est la politique
Laetitia et également sur ce que vous
avez dit d'abord il faut savoir quand
même que si jamais Mélenchon
l'hypothèse et peu probable enfin si
Mélenchon avait une majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale il pourrait
contraindre le président de la
République de le choisir comme premier
ministre
je vais t'expliquer ça s'est déjà fait
avec Mitterrand en 86 en 86 la droite
gagne les élections Mitterrand ne veut
pas de Chirac Premier ministre il
propose d'autres solutions et la droite
fait la grève des premiers ministres en
disant ce sera Chirac ou personne donc
alors il faut qu'il tienne c'est trop
voilà c'est ce que j'allais vous dire
c'est trop mais enfin si on est dans une
situation semblable à celle de 86 avec
une grève des premiers ministres
à sa place il faut qu'il y ait une
majorité alternative au présent
tout ça est très théorique parce que
effectivement mais mais c'est quand même
intéressant mais le dernier point sur
lequel jouera un système c'est que là où
Mélenchon et
politicien qui sait faire de la
politique le problème des législatives
et là et là et la raison pour laquelle
les gens s'abstiennent en législatives
c'est que c'est 577 élections dans 577
circonscriptions deux mois après la
présidentielle donc on est quand même
déjà pas mal saturé de politique et on a
tout le monde à l'impression que c'est
une élection dont la seule fonction est
en quelque sorte de donner une majorité
au président bon là il réussit quand
même à mettre un peu de suspense et en
transformant
577 élections en un plébiscite sur son
nom est-ce que pour autant leur Salvin
l'abstention pourrait être un peu moins
vaste que qu'il y a 5 ans
parce que il y a peut-être un peu plus
dangereux ce que nous dit Jean-Louis
je pense toute la stratégie de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui il essaie de continuer à
surfer sur sa vague de premier tour
finalement en espérant pouvoir continuer
à mobiliser notamment les jeunes les
milieux urbains aussi qui ont très
fortement voté pour lui je ne suis pas
sûr qu'il y arrive parce que malgré tout
et on en parlait tout à l'heure la
frustration des électeurs de Mélenchon
du premier tour a été quand même très
forte à la
au lendemain du premier tour est-ce que
ils vont réussir à se remobiliser avec
le risque de reperdre à nouveau c'est un
peu le le double effet kiss cool quoi
c'est à dire que ils se sont pris une
baffe et ils risquent de s'en prendre
une deuxième donc je suis pas sûr et
certaine effectivement que cet effet de
mobilisation marche il va y avoir une
campagne évidemment et on va voir mais
surtout je pense que ce qui est
intéressant dans cette campagne et dans
cette séquence électorale en fait depuis
la présidentielle et puis là comme vous
le disiez aussi tout à l'heure trois
personnalités très fortes on a eu on
continue à avoir des des personnalités
moi j'ai un peu le sentiment qu'on est
aussi dans une période
d'individualisation de la vie politique
c'est-à-dire que comme les citoyens la
même façon
ne sont plus dans du collectif
traditionnel ne vont plus réagir en
fonction de normes collectives
à laquelle on adhère auquel on adhère
voilà traditionnellement familialement
là aujourd'hui chacun va piocher un
petit peu et finalement individualiser
complètement à la fois son vote son
parcours sa carrière professionnelle sa
vie familial etc en politique j'ai un
peu l'impression que c'est la même chose
qui qui se passe on a de moins en moins
de collectif or là effectivement on est
dans une dans une séquence collective de
moins en moins de collectif de plus en
plus d'individuels et en ce sens et les
grands partis sont surtout à l'agonie
exactement et en ce sens c'est vraiment
une vraie transformation de du paysage
politique français et vous pensez que
est-ce que vous pensez que
il pourrait y avoir quand même des
transferts entre lecteurs d'extrême
droite extra gauche parce que quand même
le pari de Mélenchon c'est qu'il va
réussir à capter une partie de
l'électorat de l'électoral Eupen au dans
les législatives
ou union
effectivement vous pensez que c'est
possible ça c'est pas exclu parce que on
a vu en fait justement jupe pendant
toute la campagne de premier tour on a
vu des électeurs qui étaient qui hésité
entre Jean-Luc Mélenchon Marine Le Pen
et Emmanuel Macron c'est quand même
extraordinaire c'est difficile à
imaginer alors ils sont pas très
nombreux mais ils sont quand même 7 8%
vous voyez de l'électorat donc ce n'est
pas rien non plus donc effectivement je
pense que ça stratégie c'est de vouloir
essayer de les récupérer ceci dit leur
préoccupations sont pas tout à fait les
mêmes c'est là où la campagne va être
importante alors tout le monde a les
yeux rivés sur les négociations à gauche
mais Steve Jourdain vous allez nous
expliquer ça dans un instant bonsoir
Steve du côté d'Emmanuel Macron ça
négocie aussi en prévision de ces
législatives oui si vous aimez les
négociations à gauche vous allez adorer
celle-là tu vois vous allez vraiment
adorer celle-là on parle à des
négociation très dur peut-être plus dur
encore que celle qui se déroule
actuellement à gauche l'enjeu pourrait
manuel Macron est simple il lui faut une
majorité disciplinée à l'Assemblée
nationale sans cette majorité impossible
pour lui il vient de mettre en œuvre ses
réformes alors ce qui agit de la
macronie ces derniers jours ce sont les
tensions entre Emmanuel Macron et
Edouard Philippe objet des tensions la
répartition des circonscriptions pour
les législatifs Édouard Philippe et son
parti horizon visent au moins au moins
15 députés en juin pour pouvoir créer un
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale et
regardez ce que disait Emmanuel Macron
la semaine dernière à l'un de ses
proches aucune circonscription pour
horizon horizon ce sont des cons des
cons il Edouard Philippe me doit tout et
il pense qu'on est égaux il a fumé les
vapeurs du Havre voilà ce qu'on reproche
excusez un propos rapporter évidemment
c'est un propos rapporter évidemment par
nos confrères parce qu'on reproche
notamment Édouard Philippe du côté
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est de demander des
circonscriptions qui sont facilement
gagnables de ne pas viser ce qu'on
appelle des circonscriptions de conquête
bref de manquer de courage politique ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'au milieu de
cette guerre des chefs il y a un autre
chef qui lui aussi a des ambitions cet
autre chef a appelé à l'apaisement ce
matin écouter le est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'on se fasse la guerre à
l'intérieur de la majorité accepter
qu'il y ait des gens qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans les clans
qui pensent que l'approche de la
politique ou d'une approche de de cette
charge importante qu'on doit avoir pour
le pays ne s'accommodent pas des clans
et encore moins des guerres de clan je
n'ai pas toujours été d'accord avec
Édouard Philippe c'est de notoriété
publique mais enfin on a construit
ensemble et cette cette nécessité là
devrait s'imposer à tous dans les mots
j'ai assisté sur les mots et dans les
actes à côté de cette guerre des chefs
stevia d'autres lieux d'influence au
sein de la macronie oui c'est la guerre
des sous-chefs en quelque sorte ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale aujourd'hui il y a 346 députés
qui soutiennent Emmanuel Macron sur ces
346 il y en a aurait environ 310 qui
rempliraient mais pour empiler encore
faut-il être investi par la majorité
présidentielle c'est tout l'enjeu des
négociations actuelles pour les députés
autre enjeux très important pour la
macronie la création d'un éventuel grand
parti politique façon Parti démocrate
américain un grand parti qui aspirait
toutes les petites formations qui
soutiennent Emmanuel Macron en privé
personne n'y croit vraiment Édouard
Philippe n'en veut pas François Bayrou
n'en veut pas non plus ça semble donc
très mal embarqué une chose et sur
Thomas c'est que toutes ces négociations
aboutir très vite si vous présentez
Thomas au législatives la date limite
pour déposer votre candidature en
préfecture et fixée au 20 mai bah
écoutez du moment préserve merci
beaucoup je voudrais quand même signalé
que vous avez une oreillette tellement
année 90 alors que moi 2020 c'est une
inversion des logiques quoi le jeûne
c'est vous hein
allez on développe ce débat sur sur la
candidature enfin les candidats de la
République en marche moi ce que je
remarque c'est soyez potier c'est que on
a entendu la demande enfin Emmanuel
Macron dit j'ai entendu la demande
d'apaisement des Français il faudrait
peut-être qu'il l'applique à son propre
camp politique pour commencer vous voyez
ce que je veux dire oui et quand on voit
François Bayrou maire de Pau appeler à
la fin de la guerre de religion lui qui
est le biographe d'Henri IV ça
évidemment très cohérent simplement moi
que j'observe c'est que on a évidemment
une majorité qui est composite il y a
des sensibilités qui sont différentes
mais malgré tout c'est une majorité qui
reste forte c'est à dire qu'on avait en
2017 ils font s'en souvenir un tri fort
renouvellement et avec 90% à peu près je
crois des députés macronistes qui
n'avaient jamais été députés donc
c'était le premier mandat parlementaire
finalement cette majorité elle est elle
est toujours là alors certes il y a eu
un peu de perte en ligne et malgré tout
le bloc a plutôt tenu il est plutôt
discipliné et évidemment on s'attend
plutôt à un réflexe de vote
utile fidèle au président de la
République et à la majorité
présidentielle ce qui suscite évidemment
des convoitises entre les différentes
composantes leur Salvat l'une des infos
de la journée c'est que
Bernard Cazeneuve a annoncé qu'il
quitterait le Parti socialiste en cas
d'accord avec avec les filles dans cette
nouvelle union populaire si on alors ça
vaut ce que ça vaut mais si on pousse la
logique cette nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale elle va
pousser une partie des anciens électeurs
socialistes dans les bras des candidats
lrem c'est quand même une bascule qu'on
peut anticiper ça tout à fait je pense
que c'est aussi ce que ce que souhaite
et espère Emmanuel Macron et aussi en
restant en retrait dans cette période
c'est qu'effectivement il y a toute une
partie quand même du centre gauche
notamment du Parti socialiste qui serait
prêt à aller rejoindre le président de
la République donc pourquoi pas
effectivement
se servir de cette finalement de cette
union de la gauche pour
élargir aussi la majorité présidentielle
et juste pour revenir à la
personnalisation de la politique là on
revient à nouveau effectivement sur sur
cette idée
Emmanuel Macron il souhaite quand même
présidé finalement seul et ne supporte
pas en effet qu'il puisse avoir
quelqu'un d'autre que lui et Édouard
Philippe ou quelqu'un d'autre qui puisse
compter un peu trop et surtout de façon
trop indépendante pendant son
quinquennat à venir pas facile pour
Emmanuel Macron de trouver
la première ministre idéale puisque a
priori c'est son idée selon BFM TV
Valérie rabot la président du groupe
socialiste à l'Assemblée aurait refusé
Matignon alors là aussi ce sont des
propos rapports ils auraient fait la
retraite à 65 ans c'est contraire à mes
convictions dit-elle Élisée à démenti
dans la filière est-ce que est-ce que ça
se refuse Matignon Jean-Michel ah oui
c'est arrivé souvent souvent non enfin
il arrive qu'on refuse ne serait-ce que
parce que des fois on a le sentiment de
soit de ne pas être à la hauteur de la
tâche soit que la tâche est impossible
et on voit bien d'ailleurs cette
situation est assez étrange voilà voilà
un président qui a été quand même assez
confortablement élu voilà des
législatives qui ne s'annoncent pas trop
difficile pour lui et une difficulté
terrible terrible à trouver le Premier
ministre qui convient parce que
ce n'est pas Emmanuel Macron qui fait
durer le suspense je pense que c'est man
je pense que c'est compliqué aussi
aujourd'hui de faire de la politique
vous avez raison et le poste de Premier
ministre certainement un des postes
politiques les plus compliqués
de sa substance dernier thème dans ce
débat on va y consacrer quelques minutes
l'avenir politique d'Eric Zemmour
l'ancien polémiste était sur BFM TV hier
soir et pour les législatives il
hésitent encore
écoutez je vous avoue je vais vous faire
un aveu
je suis très tenté j'hésite encore pour
une raison simple
est-ce que je pourrais en me présentant
dans une circonscription
aider tous mes camarades qui sont sur le
pont j'avoue que je n'ai pas encore mais
c'est pour une histoire de quelques
jours régler cette question
Frédéric potier est-ce que vous y voyez
un manque de courage politique de la
part de celui qui cite régulièrement on
a pour les ondes général de Gaulle bah
oui franchement oui je pense qu'il
risque de souffler aussi de la
comparaison avec Marine Le Pen qui elle
sera candidate dans le Pas-de-Calais ou
à la bonne chance d'être élus donc il
lui faut trouver un lieu d'atterrissage
il faut trouver un lieu d'atterrissage
où il soit pas en concurrence avec ni le
rassemblement national ni avec la droite
donc je comprends que l'équation soit
compliquée pour monsieur Zemmour mais
c'est aussi ça la démocratie et la
démocratie c'est pas simplement faire
des débats sur des plateaux télé comme
nous ce soir c'est aussi de se présenter
devant les électeurs Jean-Louis Messika
c'est le nostalgique des nostalgiques si
je relis
c'est radicalement voir
enfin il y a quand même sur le fond de
la nostalgie de l'Empire la nostalgie de
l'Empire c'est quelque chose qui est
très très fort chez chez
Eric Zemmour et ce qui explique aussi sa
fascination pour pour Vladimir Poutine
parce que
ça veut dire oui et puis surtout il
s'identifie à l'Empire français à
l'époque où il y a la France avait des
colonies on voit bien que que la le
grand remplacement c'est une espèce de
fantasme avant nous étions nous chez eux
et maintenant ils viennent ils viennent
ils viennent chez nous et d'ailleurs le
nom même de son parti politique
reconquête dit quelque chose qui renvoie
à la période à la période à la période
impériale mais ce que je voulais dire
sur sur Zemmour c'est que lui il est
confronté à un énorme problème c'est que
Marine Le Pen ne veut pas négocier enfin
la stratégie de Marine Le Pen est très
différente de celle de de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon Marine Le Pen c'est je les
écrase et et
quoi qu'il m'en coûte parce que ça
risque de lui coûter et perdre quelques
quelques perdre des députés bien
évidemment si elle n'arrive pas parce
que vous savez alors je vais pas revenir
qui avec 50% d'abstention mais ça veut
dire concrètement qu'il n'y aura que des
duels pratiquement dans les
circonscriptions françaises et donc un
candidat Zemmour peut empêcher un ou une
candidate RN RN de de se qualifier de se
qualifier et permettre un face à face
entre un candidat mélenchianiste et un
candidat et un candidat macroniste donc
donc lui il est dans une situation où se
présenter c'est risqué de perdre et
facile qu'est-ce qui va rester de cette
aventure politique pour vous moi parce
que il met souvent en avant on va lui
faire confiance sur les chiffres qui a
plus de 120 000 adhérents du parti
reconquête c'est plus un club de fan un
club de lecteur ou alors c'est une force
politique justement c'est c'est tout
l'enjeu et je pense que c'est très
difficile aujourd'hui de pouvoir
continuer à exister à être visible après
une entrée aussi fracassante franchement
il faut le dire dans l'espace politique
français il est décrédité à un moment
donné de 15 16% des intentions de vote
en début de campagne et finalement alors
certes n'a fait que la moitié mais enfin
bon c'est pas non plus déshonorant par
rapport notamment aux princip la partie
politique donc il doit hésiter moi je
pense que c'est pas qu'une parenthèse je
pense qu'il a quand même réussi à capter
une partie de l'électorat sur des sujets
et des valeurs notamment qui sont fortes
pour une partie de la droite et toute la
question est de comment continuer à
exister avec un renne qui est quand même
très fort des républicains qui sont
déliquescence et sont partis qui
effectivement est en pleine construction
et puis surtout
à nouveau qui est très personnalisé
voilà qui est très autour du personnel
comme les autres comme les autres voilà
exactement et donc le parti personnel de
Monsieur
exactement merci à tous encore une fois
d'être venu sur le plateau de sens
public vos livres Jean-Louis Sica le
business de la haine internet la
démocratie et les réseaux sociaux ce
livre est publié chez Kalman Levy le
voilà Frédéric potier votre thriller
politique la menace 732 déjà disponible
en précommande c'est aux éditions
noir